would anybody like a breakfast burrito
there's a thing here I don't know what
it is it cheaper for bands oh it's
outside is this the thing no okay it'll
just be a reaction video to the thing
you like this I like the thing made in
Constantinople or was it Istanbul okay
another door now we're in another
person's yard there's another shed is
the thing in here oh I think the thing
is in here is this the thing
real there are the informational
placards it's about a thought so it's
real right it does exist my curiosity is
unsatisfied some things aren't meant to
be now like for example I guess the
thing
we got a melted Hershey bar this is I
can make a little hole suck it all out
okay
we have regrets been uphill for a long
time
Oh last show is over there's a ladder
here I don't know where it goes I'm
gonna try to go up
I don't feel like risking it no just
cool lighting up here it's not not built
for people of my disposition this was
really fun so many great shows some of
the great people I really like our
community John I'll see you on Tuesday